people take psychiatric medicine to  temporarily treat their diseases like  their issues what is their danger in  that i took ssris called superlex for 11  years and it took two and a half years  to go away short-term use depending on  the medication might be okay if you're  in a situation where a family member is  dying and you're so upset that you're  gonna hurt yourself then taking two  weeks of an antidepressant if that can  get you through it might not be the end  of the world there are no studies on  medications longer than six to eight  weeks on humans people are prescribed  these medications for like five years  there's no studies on the effect of the  brain of these medications after five  years now even short-term use of  benzodiazepines can cause severe  withdrawal short-acting ones seem to  cause less withdrawal than long-acting  ones so if there's anything else you can  do if that's hanging out with friends  exercising going to a low-carb diet do  that first